the MBA but none better or more fun to
follow than Kobe and Shaq they want
three titles in a row together and their
names will be linked for all time please
welcome Shaquille O'Neal
I have a magic speaking to a group of
people about Kobe Bryant vision the
context is his Hall of Fame induction
was a guest speaker when a Kobe and
essence operation but never ever could
have imagined that he hated son and
brother Kobe was a loyal friend and a
true renaissance man as many of you know
Kobe and I had a very complex
relationship throughout the years but
not unlike another leadership duo John
Lennon and Paul McCartney was created
for every led to some of the greatest
music of all time Kobe and I pushed one
another play some of the greatest
basketball of all time and I am proud
that no other team has accomplished what
the three-peat Lakers have done some
checking and the Kobe Lakers
[Applause]
and yes sometimes like immature kids we
argued we folks we ban it or insulted
each other with offhand remarks our
field but make no mistake even the folks
thought we were on bad terms when the
cameras are turned off he and I would
throw a wink at each other and say let's
go whoop some ass you never took it
seriously
in truth coping I always maintained a
deep respect and a love for one another
today I gained the day Kobe gained my
respect was the guys were complaining
she said Kobe's not passing the ball I
said I'll talk to him I said Kobe
there's no I in team and Kobe said I
know but there's an Emmy and that
[ __ ]
so we're back until rigged and uh and
Big Shot Bob I said just get the rebound
he's not passing Mambo you were taken
away from us way too soon
your next chapter of life was just
beginning but now it's time for us to
continue your legacy you said yourself
that everything negative pressure
challenges is all opportunity for me to
rouse so we now take that sage advice
and now rise from anguish and begin with
the healing just know that we got your
back little brother I'll look after
things down here I'll be sure to teach
Natalya Bianca and baby Capri all your
moves and I promise I will not teach
them my free throw techniques but for
now I'll take comfort in fact as we
speak Coby and Gigi are holding hands
walking to the nearest basketball court
Colby will show us a little Mambo rules
a day in Gigi soon masters Kobe or
Heaven's MVP I love you my man until we
meet again
[Applause]